hallo mein name ist mutter und ihr kennt
ja meine freundin martina jedenfalls
habe ich ein quiz entdeckt was heißt die
youtuber girlfriend ja hier müssen wir
ein paar fragen beantworten und dann
wird uns nachher gesagt wer meine
freundinnen bezug auf youtube ist let's
get started with jay jay wie alt bin ich
bin 18 bis 24 jahre alt glaube ich mein
geschlecht ist männlich ein concealer
myself to be
ich bin eigentlich alles so ein bisschen
ich würde sagen weil man muss sich hier
entscheiden und ich kann nicht wirklich
sagen ich bin happy bubbly konnte denn
manchmal bin ich auch schüchtern aber
ich würde ehrlich gesagt sagen wir also
so lebendig wie world of video maker
hortgebäude herr tutorial hall of the
boyfriend
das ist mein favourit hoff ich halt
meine schnauze favouriten email wort
wieso soll ich denn sagen ich mag
alpakas und die werden hier nicht
aufgelöst und das ist traurig auf friend
falls what do you do es ist halt vor
heidfeld hin und was mache ich deswegen
ich würde sagen
wait for them to get up ich würde
erstmal auslachen und damit die sagen
ihr hoch man bleibt einfach liegen
audiodeskription few mallorca mallorca
humor ist habe ich das recht
ausgesprochen tuner wird ich würde sagen
mein humor ist aaron heran weil ich
nicht witzig finden leben nahmen negativ
quality of use ich würde sagen ich bin
perfektionist ich bin auch echt
teilweise ein bisschen arrogant ich
versuche mich damals ein bisschen
zurückzuhalten
ich will zu recht sagt nicht sein aber
manchmal ist es einfach so ich würde
sagen ich bin perfektionist das ist
ein bisschen scheiße weil du versuchst
alles perfekt zu machen und kriegst es
irgendwie trotzdem nicht okay da geht es
tatsächlich nur um äußerlichkeiten dann
würde ich tatsächlich sagen das gesicht
ist eigentlich das wichtigste das ist
aber das ist nicht aufgelöst ist nur
entweder das lächeln die augen
die figur oder die haare ich würde sagen
einfach die figur damit es los und
äußerste gedacht dass julia girlfriend
it be ich würde sagen konnte dann
tatsächlich also ein bisschen
zuverlässig heißt kommt wieder
zuverlässig tut man halt mein englisch
ist wieder nach bio vom berg wie
durcheinander bin ich ich würde sagen
tatsächlich auf das gamer livestream es
also mein leben ist ein durcheinander
ich wünsche unserem bisschen kaputt im
kopf ok jetzt muss ich hier sagen wer
ich hier youtube in von denen hier auf
mich bezogen am besten angezogen ist ich
würde sagen diese tanja bury genau
ausspricht aber die hat eigentlich ganz
coolen klamotten stil und jetzt schauen
wir uns mal ans hat mit 1
was ist miranda syncsort das hätte ich
nie gedacht falls ihr euch fragt wieso
miranda aussieht so dies wundervoll you
don't have many but i think you who are
yours kennen denn kenn ich scheiß quiz
alter ich bin jetzt einfach mal auf top
four tigris gegangen zwar gibt es hier
tatsächlich noch einige ist es mehr es
gibt das holiday quiz da kann man
anschauen wie man sterben wir die
oberste sammler mission ausgewählt
yoichi agenda picken element ich finde
die luft eigentlich ganz cool car queen
of hearts ace of spades of spades
definitiv what they were youporn ach man
mama um welche uhrzeit wurde ich geboren
ich brauche das aufgrund von
wissenschaftlichen mal schauen ob ich
ein paar krieger ihr euch die besten der
welt die antwort war innerhalb von zehn
sekunden ich wurde irgendwie morgens
geboren also geben einfach mal morgens
ein meine augenfarbe ist grün durch vier
des coaches
was bedeutet teilnehmen ohne ghosting
ich habe letztes krankhafter gesehen
also ja im moment sagen nein
habe ich schon sieben oder bei welcher
zahl war ich gerade ich würde sagen ich
hab's gemacht aber ich hab nicht
gezeichnet prepaid im juli jetzt ok
klickt mit ans das und schauen uns an 0
3 in nuclear holocaust war die country
bis possible to be and unexpected well
that you be close to the epicenter vip
logen radiation therapy jfv rwd remake
etwas locker bin ich irgendwann mal
aufregende reise oder so und dann gehts
zufällig neben mir ein atomkraftwerk in
die luft und dann bin ich trotz gut
immer die anderen sachen an jubelt eine
korrekte dennoch bolden murder your
sleep und ich hab das
unwahrscheinlichste überhaupt während
einer atomkatastrophe you were having
sex julius blieb alles was ist denn das
für ein scheiß dass er dich am liebsten
gehabt woolworth savings ammons live das
finde ich richtig schön irgendwie wenn
irgendwie rein theoretisch mein sohn in
einer klippe hängen würde
keine ahnung warum war und wie ich
darauf komme und ich müsste mich quasi
opfern um jemand anderen wir sie meinen
sohn oder eine andere person die mir
nahe steht zu retten das ständig besser
richtig toller trow ich weiß nicht ob
ich mich da versteht oder allgemein
wisst was ich da meine und das ist
vielleicht auch gerade ein bisschen zu
deep um das ganze in so ein spaßiges
video mit rein zu nehmen aber ich fänd's
ganz cool wenn ich nicht normal sterbe
ich habe keine ahnung ob jetzt alle die
slide und meinl die ansicht dass kaka
aber ich fänd's cooler in
anführungszeichen wenn ich mit 80 jahren
bei einer wanderung auf dem mount
everest irgendwie sterben würde anstatt
einfach schon seitdem ich schon zwei
jahre im krankenhaus liege und dann mit
einem herzinfarkt oder so ich denke das
können wenige nachvollziehen aber das
ist meiner ansicht darauf das heißt wenn
man so ein kleines ernstes thema hier
zum ende trotzdem freunde wenn euch das
video gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen soll ich noch mehr
auf unsere christes machen als die
tochter deutsche webseiten mit dem cool
wir sehen uns irgendwann wieder
ich bin hier gerade nackt wieder